veuillez m'excuser je suis très malade
mais je tenais vraiment à faire cette
vidéo le nom du prochain film star wars
est annoncée ce sera star wars 8 the
last jedi cependant rien qu'avec ce
titre et sa couleur nous pouvons déjà
spéculé plusieurs suppositions
je vous propose donc d'analyser le titre
de ce prochain film star wars the last
jedi
nous pouvons déjà pensé à plusieurs
choses c'est la seule jedi désigne
quelqu'un mais de qui peut bien parler
ce titre nous pensons forcément à luke
skywalker qui est le tout dernier jedi
de la galaxie mais pourquoi paraît qu'il
a de découvrir la force et qui serait
certainement entraîné par l'udc
je vois deux cas de figure the last jedi
pourrait bien déterminer les
retrouvailles avec luke skywalker et le
rôle important qu'il aura dans le film
car tout on aura autour de lui
déjà qu'il y avait beaucoup d'intrigués
autour de lui dans le set
cependant la couleur du titre et rouge
tharwa recettes avait un titre jaune qui
était vaguement la couleur thème du film
et de ré par le biais de jack ou mais
ici la couleur tu es mer rouge et donne
un côté sombre donc il se pourrait bien
que le film soit tourné en faveur du
premier ordre et que nos compagnons
soient dans un sale pétrin
rien n'est laissé au hasard de l'ast
jedi sur un thème rouge
cela nous donne deux suppositions une
très probable et l'autre moins ce serait
que lui tu meurs dans star wars 8 comme
je l'avais prédit dans mon trois
théories même mark hamill l'acteur de
l'ue avait un peu fuite et le probable
futur de l'udc ou bien ré peut-être
désignée comme la dernière jedi et qu
elle basculera du mauvais côté cependant
le terme deux derniers jedi a toujours
désigné luc nous le voyons dans les
précédents films donc je pense très
sincèrement que l'histoire va tourner
autour de luc et qu'il mourra d'ailleurs
the last jedi peut désigner plusieurs
personnes aussi mais je ne pense pas
comme disait un abonné nocturne les
ficelles depuis le début et il va
certainement se mettre à agir dans le
prochain opus
d'ailleurs une question nous turlupine
mais comment disparaître carrie fisher
suite à sa mort le 27 décembre et bien
carrie fisher a déjà tourné star wars 8
avant de nous quitter sa disparition
sera très certainement dans le neuvième
opus
merci de m'avoir écouté proposé aux
théories ou sur la suite de star wars
dans les commentaires c'est à regret que
le live earth soit avec vous